Shure:  看杨老板累的
Shure: Look at Jake, he's exhausted.
Shure:  给杨老板
Shure: Give it to Jake.
Katrina: 杨老板要喝豆汁
Katrina: Jake wants to drink Douzhi.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Alice:生蚝
Alice: Oysters.
Jake: 行行行真的真的
Jake: Sure, sure, really, really.
Shure:  补补这3新币
Shure: Top up this 3 Sing dollars.
Jake: 补补补补
Jake: Top up, top up.
Jake: 我去
Jake: I'll go.
Jake: 一个10块钱够了
Jake: One for 10 dollars is enough.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Alice:这一共三新币
Alice: This total is 3 Sing dollars.
Shure:  一共3星币啊
Shure: The total is 3 Sing dollars, huh.
Jake: 我知道就是大概一个10新币
Jake: I know, it's about 10 Sing dollars each.
Alice:一个10新币
Alice: One for 10 Sing dollars.
Shure:  就是在在在新加坡的
Shure: That's in, in, in Singapore.
Alice:真的假的
Alice: Really?
Jake: 对在我在我家门口的那个商场里边
Jake: Yeah, at the mall near my house.
Lucia:  为什么
Lucia: Why?
Lucia:  你们不是靠海吗
Lucia: Aren't you guys by the sea?
Lucia:  怎么还这么贵
Lucia: Why is it still so expensive?
Jake: 我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 他就是这个价啊
Jake: That's just the price.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jake: 一个10新币
Jake: One for 10 Sing dollars.
Shure:  快给杨老板补补
Shure: Quickly, give Jake a top up.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  3新币咱可劲吃
Shure: 3 Sing dollars, we can eat a lot.
Jake: 这多少个
Jake: How many is this?
Jake: 这几个呀几个呀一二
Jake: How many are there? One, two...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  10个左右大概
Shure: About 10, roughly.
Jake: 10个100新币
Jake: 10 for 100 Sing dollars.
Jake: 500块钱你花了3
Jake: You spent 3 out of 500 yuan.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 你花了3新币
Jake: You spent 3 Singapore dollars.
Shure:  3新币
Shure: 3 Singapore dollars.
Lucia:  一共三新币
Lucia: A total of 3 Singapore dollars.
Shure:  一共3新币
Shure: A total of 3 Singapore dollars.
Shure:  19块9啊 18块9是吧
Shure: 19.9 yuan, or 18.9 yuan, right?
Shure:  3新币差不多
Shure: About 3 Singapore dollars.
Jake: 是是是你这大
Jake: Yes, yes, this is quite...
Alice:晚上就要拆开
Alice: We'll have to open it tonight.
Jake: 你这哈哈哈
Jake: You... hahaha.
Jake: 中国我当500多了
Jake: In China, I would consider this over 500.
Jake: 哈哈哈虚报虚报
Jake: Hahaha, an overestimation, an overestimation.
Shure:  虚报
Shure: Overestimation.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 这个还是能感觉出来的
Jake: You can still feel it though.
Jake: 呵呵这in w的这个
Jake: Haha, this in W's...
Shure:  面包
Shure: Bread.
Alice:你去选你想要的
Alice: You go pick what you want.
Katrina: 我就买那普通的切片面包就行
Katrina: I'll just get the regular sliced bread.
Katrina: 明天早饭是自己弄是吧
Katrina: We're making our own breakfast tomorrow, right?
Shure:  鲜软
Shure: Fresh and soft.
Katrina: 就随便拿
Katrina: Just grab whatever.
Katrina: 这种我都行
Katrina: Any type is fine with me.
Shure:  现代吐司来吧
Shure: Let's go with modern toast.
Katrina: 搞奶酪吗
Katrina: Should we get cheese?
Katrina: 还是搞果酱
Katrina: Or should we get jam?
Shure:  啊蒜还有啊
Shure: Ah, garlic, we still have some.
Shure:  咱们昨天买的那个蒜还有啊有啊
Shure: The garlic we bought yesterday, we still have it, right?
Tasha: 有
Tasha: Yes.
Shure:  没有辣的了
Shure: No more spicy ones left.
Katrina: 两袋搞一点什么呢
Katrina: What should we do with these two bags?
Shure:  不不不这跟小女孩小男孩
Shure: No, no, no, this has nothing to do with little girls or boys.
Shure:  没有没有没有没有关系
Shure: It has nothing, nothing to do with it.
Shure:  确实带巴而且
Shure: It's definitely connected though, and...
Shure:  子丑寅卯
Shure: Zi, Chou, Yin, Mao.
Shure:  三点子丑寅卯
Shure: At three o'clock, Zi, Chou, Yin, Mao.
Shure:  加8加八九
Shure: Add 8, add 8, 9.
Shure:  9加8 是17正好
Shure: 9 plus 8 is 17, exactly.
Shure:  然后是未时是不
Shure: Then it's Wei hour, right?
Shure:  感觉OK
Shure: Feels OK.
Shure:  需要再拿
Shure: Need to get more.
Alice:番茄酱
Alice: Ketchup.
Alice:那个
Alice: That one.
Shure:  番茄酱
Shure: Ketchup.
Alice:她去找番茄酱了
Alice: She went to get the ketchup.
Shure:  啊好
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure:  杨老板累了
Shure: Jake is tired.
Jake: 一般啊
Jake: Just usual.
Shure:  压地下了已经
Shure: It's already underground.
Alice:你这边还有时间吗
Alice: Do you still have time over there?
Jake: 有吧我觉得还有40分钟左右
Jake: I think there's about 40 minutes left.
Jake: 肢解了放这了
Jake: Dismembered and placed here.
Lucia:  对上次逛了时候还是鲜活的
Lucia: Yeah, last time it was still fresh when we shopped.
Lucia:  这次已经变成冷藏的
Lucia: This time it's already refrigerated.
Lucia:  AI记着哈哈
Lucia: AI remembers, haha.
Shure:  call back一下是吗
Shure: Call back, right?
Katrina: 油油拿了是吧
Katrina: You took the oil, right?
Shure:  油有家里有油
Shure: Yes, there's oil at home.
Katrina: 那就OK了
Katrina: Then it's okay.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 够了
Katrina: It's enough.
Shure:  车子都放不下了
Shure: The car can't fit any more.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  老板的眼神感觉
Shure: The boss's expression...
Jake: 哈哈哈今天只有一车还行
Jake: Hahaha, today it's just one car, not bad.
Shure:  感觉钱包又被掏空了一次是吧
Shure: Feels like the wallet got emptied again, right?
Shure: （歌词） 啊啊啊我不要
Shure: (Lyrics) Ah, ah, ah, I don't want to...
Shure:  （歌词）抢不回来
Shure: (Lyrics) Can't get it back...
Shure:  （歌词）我不谈我不谈
Shure: (Lyrics) I won't talk, I won't talk...
Shure:  （歌词）又不回来
Shure: (Lyrics) Won't come back...
Shure:  哎哪边是结账来着
Shure: Hey, where's the checkout?
Shure:  哦这呢
Shure: Oh, here it is.
Katrina: 这边
Katrina: This way.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure:  怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure:  为什么
Shure: Why?
Katrina: 咋了
Katrina: What's up?
Tasha:  啊没咋
Tasha: Ah, nothing.
Tasha:  因为这两个才200
Tasha: Because these two are just 200.
Tasha:  可要40块钱
Tasha: But it costs 40 bucks.
Tasha:  这个300克
Tasha: This is 300 grams.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure:  真的吧
Shure: Really, right?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Oh.
Lucia:  会员免费领菜去
Lucia: Members get free vegetables.
Katrina: 那我们是会员不
Katrina: So, are we members?
Katrina: 我们买这么多东西了
Katrina: We bought so many things.
Katrina: 可以送我们一袋金针菇吗呵
Katrina: Can you give us a bag of enoki mushrooms?
Shure: 拿三个袋吧先咱
Shure: Let's take three bags first.
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Alright.
Shure:  来吧开始吧
Shure: Come on, let's start.
Lucia:  我再去拿个车过来
Lucia: I'll go get another cart.
Lucia:  然后我们扫完的可以放另一个车里
Lucia: Then we can put the scanned items in the other cart.
Shure:  会员登录
Shure: Member login.
Shure:  今天谁登录啊
Shure: Who's logging in today?
Katrina: 微微
Katrina: Tasha.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Alice:我也行
Alice: I can do it too.
Katrina: 你也行是吧那你行
Katrina: You can? Then you do it.
Alice:看我有那个啥
Alice: Look, I have that thing.
Alice:把我家地址给挡了
Alice: Block my home address.
Jake: 我我我试试
Jake: I'll try, I'll try.
Jake: 这那个用的什么码呀
Jake: What code does it use?
Shure:  盒马APP
Shure: Hema app.
Jake: 一定要盒马是吧
Jake: It has to be Hema, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Alice:我有但是我
Alice: I have it, but I...
Jake: 没有啥也没有
Jake: No, I don't have anything.
Alice:现在可以关吗
Alice: Can I turn it off now?
Jake: 呃你你我有你要一定要关吗干嘛呢
Jake: Uh, you... do you really need to turn it off?
Tasha:  干嘛呢
Tasha: What are you doing?
Shure:  我们在付钱
Shure: We're paying.
Jake: 那
Jake: Then...
Alice:呀就把我家地址给漏了
Alice: Oh no, my home address is exposed.
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Yes, you can.
Shure:  可以APP下一个
Shure: You can download an app.
Jake: 好那请吧
Jake: Okay, please go ahead.
Jake: 去吧就
Jake: Go ahead.
Shure:  好吧那又靠你了
Shure: Alright, it's up to you again.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 但是券已经用完了是吧
Jake: But the coupons are all used up, right?
Shure:  OK看看能不能买点
Shure: OK, let's see if we can buy some.
Tasha:  看看能不能买点
Tasha: Let's see if we can buy some.
Jake: 啊不用不用不用不用不用
Jake: No, no, no, no need.
Katrina: 那你会员可以免费领吗
Katrina: Can you get it for free with your membership?
Jake: 一星币的事情用不着
Jake: It's just a star coin, no need.
Shure:  他那个付付费会员才会有这个
Shure: Only paid members get that.
Tasha:  二百九十八一年
Katrina: 要3个是不是
Katrina: Do we need three?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 这纯靠自觉呗
Katrina: This relies on honesty.
Katrina: 我多拽几个他也不知道啊
Katrina: If I grab a few more, no one would know.
Shure:  是的
Shure: True.
Tasha:  看看能不能买个这个
Tasha: Let's see if we can buy this.
Shure:  你试试吧
Shure: Give it a try.
Katrina: 对那个了吗
Katrina: Did you get that one?
Katrina: 放那个筐里到时候我们弄完了就往那边移
Katrina: Put that in the basket, and we'll move it over when we're done.
Shure:  马在哪呢
Shure: Where's the horse?
Shure:  这先先等一会
Shure: Wait a bit.
Shure:  问问工作人员吧
Shure: Let's ask the staff.
Alice:肉放一块吧
Alice: Put the meat together.
Katrina: 然后把它往那个筐里移
Katrina: Then move it to that basket.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Katrina: 流水线工作
Katrina: Assembly line work.
Alice:这个不能放下边会把它压了
Alice: Don't put this at the bottom, it'll get crushed.
Alice:先别放这个了
Alice: Don't put this here yet.
Alice:不不不这个先放外边吧
Alice: No, no, no, put this outside for now.
Alice:把肉啥的搁过来吧
Alice: Move the meat over here.
Alice:或者是冷冻的菜也先不搁
Alice: Or the frozen veggies, don't put them here yet.
Alice:肉肉成盒的搁这
Alice: Put the packaged meat here.
Alice:sorry
Alice: Sorry.
Shure:  我快转晕了
Shure: I'm getting dizzy.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:旋转跳跃
Alice: Spin and jump
Alice:还有肉没
Alice: Is there any meat left?
Shure:  这个等一会吧
Shure: Let's wait a bit for this
Alice:把那几个肉解开搁这里面吧
Alice: Unwrap those pieces of meat and put them in here
Shure:  你把肉结了
Shure: You tied up the meat
Lucia:  放不下的话就放这袋子里
Lucia: If it doesn't fit, put it in this bag
Jake:袋子哪领的呀
Jake: Where did you get the bag?
Alice:买的
Alice: Bought it
Katrina: 哎还有一盒肉
Katrina: Oh, there's another box of meat
Shure:  3个袋 4个袋子一新币差不多
Shure: About 3 or 4 bags for one dollar
Jake: 这么贵
Jake: That's expensive
Lucia:  这袋子这么贵哇
Lucia: These bags are so expensive, wow
Alice:对
Alice: Yes
Jake: 一新币啊
Tasha:  可降解
Tasha: It's biodegradable
Lucia:  现在国内的袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Even in our country now, bags are this expensive
Alice:并且他现在你外送的话必须买袋子
Alice: And if you want delivery, you have to buy the bags now
Lucia:  哦
Lucia: Oh
Jake: 这一块多钱一个袋子是吗我去
Jake: So, it's more than a dollar per bag?
Shure:  一块5一个
Shure: One costs 1.5
Shure:  哎又给你换到6了哈哈哈
Shure: Oh, they changed it to 6 now, haha
Lucia:  哎不过其实到哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh, but actually, haha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia:  不过其实到处袋子都收钱
Lucia: But actually, bags cost money everywhere
Lucia:  不过我没想到
Lucia: But I didn't expect
Lucia:  国内现在袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Bags in our country are this expensive now
Katrina: 没了这也没弄是不是
Katrina: That's it, we didn't do it, right?
Lucia:  先放这个吧
Lucia: Let's put this here first
Shure:  没了
Shure: It's gone
Alice:把那个调料给我吧
Alice: Give me that seasoning
Lucia:  他不好意思
Lucia: He's embarrassed
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure:  这个弄了吧
Shure: Let's do this
Shure:  就只有这个没动了是吧
Shure: Is this the only thing left untouched?
Alice:好这袋就这样吧再加一个也行
Alice: Okay, let's leave this bag as is and add another one
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hi, hi
Shure:  我们找找
Shure: Let's look
Shure:  他码呢
Shure: Where is his code?
Shure:  他码没了
Shure: The code's gone.
Shure:  是这个吗
Shure: Is it this one?
Katrina: 后面反面
Katrina: The back side.
Katrina: 反面是条形嘛
Katrina: The back side is a barcode, right?
Tasha:  应该第一天就开
Tasha: Should have started on the first day.
Shure:  OK搞定
Shure: OK, done.
Jake: 卡多少钱
Jake: How much for the card?
Tasha:  只要298 跟嫁入土门是一个价格
Tasha: It's only 298, same price as marrying into the Tumen family.
Lucia:  这个会这个外面会有水蒸气的话
Lucia: Will there be steam outside of it?
Lucia:  要不然跟这个放一块
Lucia: Otherwise, put it together with this.
Lucia:  因为面包袋子是纸
Lucia: Because the bread bag is paper.
Shure:  好来来来
Shure: Alright, come on, come on.
Lucia:  这个放到这边
Lucia: Put this over here.
Lucia:  然后这个放在这行吗
Lucia: Then put this one here, okay?
Tasha:  付钱了吗已经
Tasha: Have you paid already?
Shure:  大小姐
Shure: Missy.
Shure:  对到付钱了
Shure: Yes, already paid.
Shure:  到最需要你的时候了
Shure: Now we need you the most.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina: 你你是怎么给他报账的
Katrina: How do you report to him?
Katrina: 每天都给他报账吗
Katrina: Do you report to him every day?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Alice:沉的给男人吧
Alice: Leave the heavy stuff to the men.
Lucia:  这个
Lucia: This one.
Jake: 护蛋使者
Jake: Egg protector.
Shure:  这个又得端着了是吗
Shure: Do I have to hold this again?
Jake: 护蛋使者
Jake: Egg protector.
Lucia:  我端着吧
Lucia: I'll hold it.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  护蛋
Shure: Protecting the egg.
Katrina: 放我袋子里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Jake: 那个还有是吗
Jake: Is there more?
Katrina: 那披萨我也来拿
Katrina: I'll take the pizza too.
Alice:那你喝的你拿着还是给你放着
Alice: Do you want to hold your drink or should I put it down?
Lucia:  这个能能放下吗
Lucia: Can this fit?
Lucia:  放不下我就拿着好了
Lucia: If not, I'll hold it.
Shure:  蛋还是
Shure: The egg or...
Shure:  手拿吧哦
Shure: Handheld, oh.
Shure:  还没到那
Shure: Not there yet.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Lucia: 先放到车里
Lucia: Let's put it in the car first.
Lucia:  然后一会提的时候再拿出来
Lucia: Then we'll take it out when we need to lift it.
Katrina: go go go
Katrina: Go go go!
Shure:  哦没买百事可乐我靠
Shure: Oh, we didn't buy Pepsi, damn it.
Jake: 为什么要百事可乐
Jake: Why do we need Pepsi?
Shure:  因为腌东西的那个百事会更甜一点
Shure: Because Pepsi is a bit sweeter for marinating stuff.
Shure:  可口反正它就不好喝
Shure: Coke just doesn't taste as good.
Jake: 好这能推到哪
Jake: Okay, so how far can we push this?
Shure:  对呀好像也就这
Shure: Yeah, looks like just this far.
Lucia:  他不拦着咱咱就往外推哈哈哈
Lucia: If no one stops us, we'll just push it out, haha.
Shure:  但也上不去啊主要是
Shure: But we can't get it up, that's the main issue.
Jake: 挡着挡着挡着挡着挡着挡着
Jake: Block it, block it, block it.
其他人：哎你好车只能到这了
Others: Hey, the car can only go this far.
Lucia:  哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake: 失败大失败
Jake: Failure, big failure.
Katrina: 我来拿这个吧
Katrina: I'll take this.
Shure:  直接这么拿应该就没问题
Shure: Carrying it like this should be fine.
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha:  好好
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Shure:  那要要不你护蛋吧
Shure: How about you protect the eggs?
Alice:护蛋
Alice: Protect the eggs.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Lucia:  这个
Lucia: This.
其他人：人多力量大一人一个就完了
Others: Strength in numbers, everyone takes one.
Alice:护蛋使者是吗
Alice: Egg protector, right?
Shure:  当当当当当当当当当当当当当当当
Shure: Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Alice:谁把我的蛋撞碎了我就把谁撞死
Alice: If anyone breaks my egg, I'll break their head.
Lucia:  哈哈哈好可怕
Lucia: Hahaha, that's terrifying.
Shure:  我们回去又可以坐保姆车了
Shure: We can ride the nanny van back again.
Lucia:  每天被撞的现代人
Lucia: Modern people always getting bumped around.
Alice:精神状态良好
Alice: Mental state is good.
Katrina: 现几点钟
Katrina: What time is it now?
Shure:  5点多回去
Shure: A little past 5, heading back.
Shure:  5点半
Shure: Half past 5.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哎你别说了
Katrina: Hahaha, hey, stop talking.
Shure:  我也工作一会
Shure: I'll work for a bit too.
Shure:  不然话立德该发飙了
Shure: Or else the boss will go crazy.
Shure:  妈的你小子提了5天线上
Shure: Damn, you took 5 days off online.
Shure:  然后一点活不干哈哈哈
Shure: And didn't do any work, hahaha.
Katrina: 咱这是还要上去吧我记得
Katrina: We're going up again, right? I remember.
Lucia:  对对就是为了融入人类社会
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, it's to blend into human society.
Lucia:  我不得不把自己伪装的像人类一样
Lucia: I had to disguise myself to look like a human.
Shure:  爬上去才对
Shure: Climb up, that's the way.
Lucia:  哈哈哈微微露出一个轻蔑的笑容
Lucia: Hahaha, she gave a slight smirk.
Alice:上吧
Alice: Go on.
Shure:  从这上去
Shure: Go up from here.
Lucia:  哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  （歌词）太空里面的人你们好吗
Shure: (lyrics) Hey people in space, how are you doing?
Shure:  （歌词）还记得笑吗
Shure: (lyrics) Do you still remember how to smile?
Shure:  （歌词）记得我吗
Shure: (lyrics) Do you remember me?
Shure:  （歌词）记得歌唱记得拉
Shure: (lyrics) Remember to sing, remember to pull.
Katrina: 杨导说他21号没空
Katrina: Director Yang said he's not available on the 21st.
Shure:  你干嘛呢下午
Shure: What are you doing this afternoon?
Alice:打车吧
Alice: Let's take a cab.
Lucia:  我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia:  竟然扭不出来
Lucia: I can't twist it out.
Tasha:  这肯定是有硬币要投币的
Tasha: There must be coins needed for this.
Shure:  们6个人正好打一个商务
Shure: Six of us can fit in a business car.
Jake: 对打个商务好
Jake: Yeah, let's get a business one.
Jake: 就在这等着吧
Jake: Let's wait here.
Jake: 哎这边我看一下在哪打车哈
Jake: Hey, let me check where to get a cab.
Shure:  应该这就行
Shure: This should be fine.
Shure:  那能停公交就能那啥
Shure: If buses can stop here, so can we.
Shure:  nice烫
Shure: Nice and warm.
Jake: 就是或者就在这个地方也很
Jake: Or we could just stay at this spot, it's also very...
Jake: 也很酷炫
Jake: ...cool.
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This place.
Lucia:  要扫一下喜茶吗
Lucia: Want to scan for some Hey Tea?
Jake: 我先打车
Jake: I'll call a cab first.
Shure:  喜茶没开吧那个
Shure: Hey Tea isn't open, right?
Tasha:  应该在门外开了吧
Tasha: It should be open outside, right?
Lucia:  哈哈打哈欠会传染
Lucia: Haha, yawning is contagious.
Jake: 那边那头去
Jake: That way, over there.
Shure: 出门左拐
Shure: Turn left after you exit.
Jake: 看一下有更好的地方吗
Jake: Let's see if there's a better spot.
Shure:  门口不能停
Shure: We can't stop at the entrance.
Jake: 还是还是这吧行吧
Jake: Still, let's stay here, shall we?
Shure:  出门右拐
Shure: Turn right after you exit.
Jake: 哎啥玩意
Jake: What is this?
Alice:这个洞特别像一个怪笑的
Alice: This hole looks like a creepy smile.
Lucia:  啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 这吧行吧
Jake: Is this okay?
Jake: 这好
Jake: This is good.
Shure: 对吧
Shure: Right?
Alice:两个大蝴蝶眼
Alice: Two big butterfly eyes.
Shure: 啊这就行
Shure: Ah, this works.
Shure:  OK这这可以可以OK就是
Shure: OK, this is fine, OK.
Jake: 行好
Jake: Alright, good.
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's wrong?
Alice:洗不掉了
Alice: It won't wash off.
Shure:  然后谢斌竹随便给我拿点衣服
Shure: Then Xie Binzhu just grabbed me some clothes.
Shure:  我收拾行李让他给我收拾
Shure: I packed my luggage, he packed for me.
Shure:  他给我拿了4件外套一个t恤
Shure: He got me 4 jackets and a T-shirt.
Shure:  你这好吧
Shure: Is this okay for you?
Shure:  可能躺累了吧
Shure: Maybe you're tired from lying down.
Shure:  谁说躺着不算一种剧烈运动呢是吧
Shure: Who says lying down isn't a form of intense exercise, right?
Alice:好乐观我看成乐欢了
Alice: So optimistic, I thought it was "joyful."
Alice:啊乐观啊
Alice: Ah, optimistic.
Lucia:  你如生活的
Lucia: How you live your life...
Alice:哇哇蛋你没事吧
Alice: Wow, egg, are you okay?
Shure:  完了
Shure: It's over.
Shure:  护蛋使者
Shure: Egg protector.
Shure:  你的任务巨大我跟你讲
Shure: Your mission is huge, I'm telling you.
Jake: 还有11分钟才到
Jake: There are still 11 minutes to go.
Jake: 所以放地上吧
Jake: So just leave it on the ground.
Shure:  先放一会吧
Shure: Leave it for now.
Shure:  躺地上
Shure: Lie on the ground.
Shure:  （歌词）我在无言的夜
Shure: (Lyrics) In the silent night...
Shure:  洋葱买的吧
Shure: You bought the onions, right?
Shure:  洋葱买的
Shure: Bought the onions.
Alice:买了紫皮的
Alice: Bought the purple ones.
Shure: （歌词） 的歌唱记得
Shure: (Lyrics) Remember the song...
Lucia:  好好吧
Lucia: Okay, fine.
Lucia:  你对生活的热爱
Lucia: Your love for life...
Lucia:  sorry看错了
Lucia: Sorry, I misread it.
Jake: 这样可以拍吧
Jake: Can we shoot it like this?
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Jake: 这样可以拍吗
Jake: Can we shoot it like this?
Shure:  什么奇怪的事情
Shure: What a strange thing.
Lucia:  你醒了
Lucia: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: You're awake, hahaha, brilliant!
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ahahaha
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake: 好就这样吧
Jake: Alright, just like this.
Shure:  来我们叫醒一下AI
Shure: Come on, let's wake up the AI.
Jake: 就这样挺好
Jake: This is good.
Jake: 来来来叫醒叫醒一下
Jake: Come on, wake up, wake up.
Jake: 叫醒服务
Jake: Wake-up service.
Katrina: 到底谁啊
Katrina: Who is it?
Lucia:  呃他的手机
Lucia: Uh, his phone.
Shure:  咱们一个一个露出来吧
Shure: Let's reveal one by one.
Shure:  咱们先拍一张
Shure: Let's take a photo first.
Shure:  然后拍个视频
Shure: Then shoot a video.
Katrina: 1234还差一个人呢
Katrina: 1, 2, 3, 4, we're still missing one person.
Jake: 好等一下
Jake: Okay, wait a second.
Lucia:  要合个影
Lucia: Let's take a group photo.
Shure:  喝牛奶喝的
Shure: Drinking milk.
Shure:  有一人没露出来快快快
Shure: Someone isn't in the shot, hurry up.
Jake: 快快快
Jake: Hurry up.
Jake: 晚了再来一次
Jake: Too late, let's do it again.
Alice:还没带眼镜呢
Alice: I haven't put on my glasses yet.
Shure:  而且你没戴眼镜
Shure: And you didn't wear your glasses.
Alice:来了
Alice: Here I come.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You're awake.
Shure:  那已经是2077年了
Shure: It's already the year 2077.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 等会我把这个带上忘了
Jake: Wait a minute, I forgot to put this on.
Shure:  Wifi没带上
Shure: You didn't bring the WiFi.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没
Jake: Hahahahahaha no
Shure:  接收不着信号了
Shure: Can't get a signal.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure:  好心急还补一下
Shure: Feeling anxious, need to top up.
Lucia:  马上收不到信号了
Lucia: The signal's about to go.
Shure:  是吗让自己看的像个活人一样
Shure: Really? Make yourself look like a living person.
Alice:怎么按反了呢啊
Alice: How did I press it the wrong way?
Alice:没有
Alice: No, I didn't.
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 有点歪呃没关系歪对啊
Jake: It's a bit crooked, but it's fine. Crooked is good.
Alice:有点歪说实话
Alice: It's a bit crooked, honestly.
Shure:  不是可以拍这个转场
Shure: Can't we shoot this transition?
Lucia:  哈哈搅动转场
Lucia: Haha, spinning transition.
Jake: 好再来
Jake: Okay, let's do it again.
Tasha: 怎么这么暗
Tasha: Why is it so dark?
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  这次非常帅
Shure: This time looks great.
Jake: 这次很好
Jake: This time is good.
Alice:好
Alice: Good.
Jake: 那视频一个一个出
Jake: Then let's release the videos one by one.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 一个一个进来
Jake: One by one, come in.
Jake: 然后你醒了
Jake: Then you wake up.
Jake: 你写哪你醒了
Jake: Which part did you write, you wake up.
Katrina: 要说这句话是吗
Katrina: Should I say this line?
Shure:  来吧好
Shure: Come on, okay.
Jake: 呵要吗
Jake: Haha, do you need it?
Jake: 可以要
Jake: You can have it.
Shure:  好快快先撤出来
Shure: Okay, quickly, let's pull it out first.
Alice:来呀谁呀
Alice: Come on, who is it?
Shure:  从杨老板开始
Shure: Start with Jake.
Jake:你醒了
Jake: You wake up.
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You wake up.
Shure:  你就不知道走了
Shure: You just don't know and leave.
Jake: 进来就呆着
Jake: Come in and stay put.
Jake: 重来重来重来
Jake: Again, again, again.
Shure:  哎重来没有默契没有啊
Shure: Hey, again, no coordination, none at all.
Tasha:  什么你醒了
Tasha: What, you wake up.
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You wake up.
Jake: 来来来闪开
Jake: Come on, move out of the way.
Lucia:  那个表情包
Lucia: That meme.
Tasha:  哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Lucia:  你醒了快起来做作业哈哈
Lucia: You wake up, get up and do your homework, haha.
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You wake up.
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You wake up.
Lucia:  你醒了
Lucia: You wake up.
Tasha:  醒了
Tasha: Woke up.
Katrina: 你醒了
Katrina: You wake up.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Katrina: 你醒了
Katrina: You're awake.
Shure:  你醒了吗
Shure: Are you awake?
Jake: 2077啊哈哈哈哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: 2077, hahaha, you idiot.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahaha
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha:  哈哈哈我靠哈
Tasha: Hahaha, oh my gosh.
Katrina: 这是噩梦你知道吗这噩
Katrina: This is a nightmare, you know?
Tasha:  哈好
Tasha: Haha, okay.
Lucia:  哈哈瞬间变恐怖片
Lucia: Haha, it suddenly turned into a horror movie.
Jake: 我靠很难
Jake: Oh my gosh, this is hard.
Jake: 哈哈哈直接晕倒
Jake: Hahaha, just fainted.
Alice:你不要过来呀
Alice: Don't come over here.
Lucia:  你不要过来呀你不要过来
Lucia: Don't come over here, don't come over here.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈根本醒不了
Jake: Hahaha, can't wake up at all.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Shure:  直接鬼压床了
Shure: It's like sleep paralysis.
Jake: ha ha
Jake: Haha
Shure:  魇到了
Shure: Had a nightmare.
Jake: 看一眼车
Jake: Let's check the car.
Jake: 还有8分钟
Jake: Still 8 minutes left.
Jake: 还能再整点活
Jake: We can still get some work done.
Jake: 好好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Lucia:  新物种生活
Lucia: New species life.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Alice:有鬼
Alice: There's a ghost.
Katrina: 太恐怖了这
Katrina: This is too scary.
Jake: 新物种生活确实
Jake: New species life, indeed.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Shure:  我靠新物种生活
Shure: Oh my gosh, new species life.
Shure:  上面这字还很应景
Shure: The text above is quite fitting.
Shure:  （歌词）去到哪里会不会一无所我知
Shure: (Lyrics) No matter where I go, will I know nothing at all?
Jake: 最后一天的开场视频都有了
Jake: We have the opening video for the last day.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  对噔噔噔
Shure: Right, dun dun dun.
Shure:  你醒吧然后就大家就都退出去了
Shure: Wake up and then everyone just leaves.
Shure:  我那个叫什么10秒点出率
Shure: What's that thing called, 10-second output rate?
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, haha.
Shure:  就卡在我那10秒了
Shure: It got stuck at my 10 seconds.
Jake: 丰收歌曲
Jake: Harvest song.
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure:  （歌词）自由经过了山
Shure: (Lyrics) Freedom passed over the mountains.
Shure:  （歌词）我想开着我的烂摩托转一转
Shure: (Lyrics) I want to ride my beat-up motorcycle around.
Shure:  （歌词）可惜我的心
Shure: (Lyrics) But sadly my heart...
Shure:  （歌词）我可惜我把车卖了
Shure: (Lyrics) Sadly, I sold my bike.
Shure:  （歌词）我的心呀我的心
Shure: (Lyrics) Oh my heart, oh my heart...
Shure:  （歌词）变成了处处处处都给你
Shure: (Lyrics) Turned into everywhere, everywhere, all for you.
Alice:还有大概半个小时能录
Alice: There's about half an hour left to record.
Jake: 就上车就关掉
Jake: Just get in the car and turn it off.
Lucia:  当前网络不稳定
Lucia: The current network is unstable.
Shure:  （歌词）躲在屋檐的
Shure: (Lyrics) Hiding under the eaves...
Shure:  （歌词）你的笑吗
Shure: (Lyrics) Your smile...
Shure:  少喝点奶吧可
Shure: Drink less milk, okay?
Jake: 这地挺酷
Jake: This place is pretty cool.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  刷哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  啊你在拍照啊
Shure: Oh, you're taking pictures?
Jake: 等会等会等会你你你
Jake: Wait, wait, wait, you, you, you...
Shure:  你浪费我的表情了
Shure: You wasted my expression.
Jake: 你从后面绕过来吧
Jake: Come around from the back.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 我开始我开始录了
Jake: I'm starting, I'm starting to record.
Shure:  刷哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈可以吧
Shure: Hahaha, is this okay?
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure:  到了吗车看眼
Shure: Are we there? Look at the car.
Shure:  车看眼车
Shure: Look at the car, the car.
Jake: 还有5分钟
Jake: Five more minutes.
Jake: 出去等着吧
Jake: Wait outside.
Shure:  咱们要控制变量
Shure: We need to control the variables.
Shure:  比如说你现在不喝牛奶了
Shure: For example, if you stop drinking milk now.
Shure:  然后你看你突然气血好了
Shure: Then you see your energy suddenly improves.
Shure:  那就说明什么
Shure: What does that mean?
Jake: 走吧出去吧
Jake: Let's go outside.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  （歌词）起来饥寒交迫的人
Shure: (Lyrics) Rise up, you who are starving and freezing...
Shure:  （歌词）  全世界
Shure: (Lyrics) The whole world
Tasha:  最帅的人会拎两个好
Tasha: The most handsome person will carry two good ones.
Shure:  杨老板哈哈哈
Shure: Jake hahaha
Jake: 你哈哈
Jake: You haha
Jake: 你最帅不用不用不用一一一
Jake: You are the most handsome, no need, no need, no need, one by one
Shure:  杨老板哎
Shure: Jake hey
Shure:  别客气哎呀呀呀呀
Shure: Don't be so polite, oh my god
Jake: 呃呃呃这么客气
Jake: Uh, uh, uh, so polite
Shure:  行吧那就给你吧
Shure: Alright then, I'll give it to you.
Jake: 蛋呢蛋在蛋在
Jake: Where's the egg? The egg is here.
Shure:  蛋护好蛋啊可
Shure: Protect the egg well, okay?
Jake: 蛋在哪啊
Jake: Where's the egg?
Shure: 蛋护好蛋
Shure: Protect the egg.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  你在反复欣赏那个视频是吗我天
Shure: Are you watching that video over and over again? Oh my god.
Jake: 没有最帅的人
Jake: No, the most handsome person.
Alice:你没有反复吧哈哈
Alice: You didn't watch it repeatedly, right? Haha
Lucia:  把我吓得又倒头就睡真的
Lucia: It scared me so much, I immediately fell asleep again.
Jake: 走上道路口
Jake: Walk to the intersection.
Jake: 这过得去吧
Jake: Can we get through here?
Shure:  过得去从那过
Shure: Yeah, you can get through from there.
Shure:  （歌词）去到哪里
Shure: (Lyrics) Wherever you go
Shure: （歌词） 会不会一无所知
Shure: (Lyrics) Will you be completely ignorant
Shure:  你又翻山越岭
Shure: You crossed mountains and valleys again.
Shure:  （歌词）我为你翻山越岭
Shure: (Lyrics) I crossed mountains and valleys for you.
Shure:  （歌词）却很平淡风景
Shure: (Lyrics) But the scenery is very plain.
Shure:  哪能过去
Shure: How can you get past?
Shure:  我靠这
Shure: Damn this
Tasha:  那当然是翻山越岭
Tasha: Of course it's crossing mountains and valleys.
Shure:  他到哪了
Shure: Where did he go?
Shure:  我看一眼
Shure: Let me take a look.
Jake: 三分钟
Jake: Three minutes.
Shure:  就在咱们面前是吧
Shure: Right in front of us, right?
Shure:  这过不去应该
Shure: We probably can't get through here.
Shure:  那咱们从那绕一下吧走吧
Shure: Let's go around from there, shall we?
Jake: 啊他
Jake: Ah, he
Jake: 他说可以开进来
Jake: He said he can drive in.
Shure:  不这是非机动车道
Shure: No, this is a non-motorized lane.
Shure:  他进不来的
Shure: He can't come in.
Tasha:  他可以看到外面那个吧
Tasha: He should be able to see outside, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  不是但是咱们也过不去啊
Shure: But we can't get through, right?
Tasha:  过了去吧
Tasha: Let's try.
Shure:  他很窄真的很窄
Shure: It's very narrow, really narrow.
Jake: 走试试
Jake: Let's try to walk through.
Jake: 那要不怎么照
Jake: Otherwise, how do we take the photo?
Tasha:  哎你小心摄像头
Tasha: Hey, watch out for the camera.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one?
Tasha:  我是说钻的时候
Tasha: I mean when you crawl through.
Shure:  钻的是吧
Shure: Crawl through, right?
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure:  你
Shure: You...
Shure:  要钻过去是吧
Shure: Need to crawl through, right?
Jake: 哎从旁边不能过吗
Jake: Hey, can't we go from the side?
Shure:  旁边
Shure: The side...
Tasha:  可以呀
Tasha: Yes, we can.
Shure:  真费劲吧
Shure: It's really difficult, right?
Shure:  杨老板你你你你能吗
Shure: Jake, can you do it?
Jake: 哈哈哈我有可能的吧
Jake: Hahaha, I might be able to.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Katrina: 当心车当心车
Katrina: Watch out for the car, watch out for the car.
Shure:  哦这辆什么
Shure: Oh, this one...
Shure:  337是吗
Shure: Is it 337?
Jake: 776
Jake: 776.
Shure:  啊不是
Shure: Ah, no.
Tasha:  那就是
Tasha: Then it's...
Shure:  那辆不是保姆车
Shure: That one isn't the nanny car.
Tasha:  是这辆吗好吧
Tasha: Is it this one? Alright then.
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Tasha:  这辆吗
Tasha: This one?
Shure:  有可不是
Shure: Could be, no.
Tasha:  怎么这么多6座车
Tasha: Why are there so many 6-seater cars?
Jake: 棕色别克
Jake: Brown Buick.
Jake: 776
Jake: 776.
Jake: 那个像吗
Jake: Does that one look like it?
Shure:  有点像
Shure: Kind of.
Shure:  疑似
Shure: Suspected.
Shure:  776 对没错
Shure: 776, yes, that's right.
Tasha:  这是棕色吗
Tasha: Is this brown?
Jake: 就是他
Jake: It's this one.
Shure:  yes
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 太对了
Jake: Absolutely.
Tasha:  都是打领带的
Tasha: They all wear ties.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Katrina: 要放后备箱吗
Katrina: Should we put it in the trunk?
Shure:  哪有后备箱姐
Shure: Where's the trunk, sis?
Lucia:  哎不放后备箱吗
Lucia: Hey, aren't we putting it in the trunk?
Shure:  啊尾号7008是吧
Shure: Ah, the number ends in 7008, right?
Jake: 对对可对了
Jake: Yes, yes, that's correct.
Shure:  啊 7008
Shure: Ah, 7008.
Lucia:  要不放一下吧
Lucia: Should we put it there?
Shure:  不是哪有后备箱啊你想想
Shure: No, where's the trunk? Think about it.
Lucia:  啊没有啊没有
Lucia: Oh, there's no trunk, right?
其他人：不是你要有箱子啊
Others: No, you need a box.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
其他人：那赶紧上啊赶紧上啊
Others: Hurry up, get in!
Shure:  这这些上来就行
Shure: These can just go on.
Alice:蛋啊你可别碎啊
Alice: The eggs, don't let them break.
其他人：滴滴专车为您服务请您系好安全带
Others: DiDi car service, please fasten your seat belts.
Shure:  我要做来的老板呗
Shure: I should be the boss here.
Jake: 呀再次保安位
Jake: Yeah, security position again.
Alice:蛋没事吧
Alice: Are the eggs okay?
Jake: 关吧
Jake: Close it.
Tasha:  没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Lucia:  理论上说是不是我理财
Lucia: Technically, I manage the finances, right?
Alice:停吧
Alice: Stop it.
Lucia:  应该是保安
Lucia: Should be security.
Lucia:  然后我下去刚好给你们一开门
Lucia: And then I go down and open the door for you.
Alice:这个可以停了吗
Alice: Can we stop this now?
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure:  没有把它录了放冰箱里吧
Shure: No, just record it and put it in the fridge.
Jake:下车开始录
Jake: Start recording when you get off.
Jake: 我录完放冰箱
Jake: I'll record and put it in the fridge.
Jake: 放到冰箱就给我导
Jake: Put it in the fridge and then transfer it to me.
Lucia:  哎所以现在要暂停吗
Lucia: So should we pause now?
Jake: 对对对就停掉停掉
Jake: Yes, yes, just stop it.
Shure:  要暂停吗
Shure: Should we pause it?
Jake: 这一路啥也不是
Jake: This whole trip is pointless.